anyway the Democrats is entering the
Congress of course when their top
interest they say one of their top
public policy priorities disarming the
population just a decade ago about a
quarter of candidates backed by the NRA
we're in fact Democrats now the number
of NRA backed House Democrats is three
meanwhile a new poll of Democrats in
early primary state says their top issue
after single-payer health care is
repealing the Second Amendment in order
to ban guns
Richard good seen as a lawyer a former
adviser to Bill and Hillary Clinton she
joins us tonight thanks for coming on
shore so is this really the time as the
country's becoming more chaotic should
disarm the population yeah so I can't
really speak for these people who
respond to this poll I can tell you what
Nancy Pelosi is talking about what House
Democrats are talking about which is
background checks which 90% plus of the
public supports which got 54 votes in
the Senate when it was to me in mansion
of putting a bill to require but if if
Democrats polled and what seems like a
legitimate poll say their number to
issue after socialized medicine is
repealing the Second Amendment
preparatory to disarming the population
you know they're gonna be calls for that
if the people voters want it you know
their representatives will call for it
is this the time and shouldn't make us
the rest of us a little nervous as
America's getting crazier obviously to
disarm normal people yeah
again I just don't buy the notion that
that was a legit poll that even a
quarter of Democrats think repealing the
Second Amendment when I think of that
what I think the Democrats are saying is
is what Justice Scalia said in the
famous Heller decision the one case that
really went to the Supreme Court where
you said a person has a right to a
handgun to protect their home period and
that legitimate regulation of guns in
terms of places that they can't be taken
schools places that you know conditions
on their sale of all those laws already
I mean I think no one's talking about
repealing that no people are and what's
mean let's stop lying just for a second
you're not gonna stop mass shootings
really unless you take all the guns away
that's the truth and everyone knows it
I mean honestly yeah so that's kind of
the goal and everyone really knows that
and I'm just wondering like what's the
argument here so if you're arguing
simultaneously that the police
a racist it can't be trusted which bado
and lots of other candidates have argued
and also the population can't be trusted
to defend itself or have firearms what
are you really saying I think what
Democrats are saying and frankly
Republicans wish they had been saying it
because the ones backed by the NRA
Barbara Comstock Mike Hoffman and
Colorado lost two Democrats saying we
want background check laws and so forth
and what they're saying is that things
have gotten out of whack the United
States is unique in the world it's not a
mental health problem there are mental
health problems everywhere else in the
world but we have this horrible gun
problem here
so actually we don't because most
Americans are not a threat to anybody
and this is what makes me nervous is a
small percentage of people commit the
overwhelming majority of shootings but
we're not thinking clearly about how to
disarm them all of these laws apply to
me I pose no threat to anyone and I
really want to be able to defend myself
I know you do too so why not leave me
out of it and normal people out of it
who pose no conceivable threat and focus
on the potential threats but no one's
ever
no one's ever up for doing that right we
all have to be disarmed why
well again no one's talking about
disarming anybody well what would we
elected officials are saying is we
should have background checks so
lunatics don't have the access to guns
the most the most recent shooting and
many of these shootings have been
committed by people who went through
background check Steven paddock with
your background check the latest shooter
in obviously who you just saw in
California went through a background
check the truth is it's not just
background checks which nobody really
opposes it's limiting the kind of
firearms you can buy limiting the size
the magazines you can use living the
kinds of ammunition you can purchase
these are laws restrictions that affect
normal people who should be able to
defend themselves why is that but when
you say that nobody really opposes when
you get Republican leaders here please
ask them to I mean let's be serious yeah
background checks are I buy gun so I
know they're in place you go through
them when you buy a gun
why would magazine restriction or an
ammo restriction or in a so-called
assault rifles restriction apply to me
what isn't why am I not trusted to buy
any kind of gun I want I'm confused
honestly well again the analogy I would
use is to the ways we basically made
cars safer these
to be a lot more fatality it's on the
road and we Institute things like
seatbelt and and airbags and other
things vehicles that could basically
crush without crushing the passenger and
and background checks is the first way
to go but but then why no sincere
question though the assault rifle ban a
gun that looks scary should be banned
okay that's the position and a lot of
Canada says they should be confiscated
why should my right to buy that gun be
abridged why not I beat no it is though
well no one's being if you subjective
way should I be able to buy that gun I'm
an American citizen I don't pose a
threat to anybody why can't I have that
gun I think the concern is that people
get their hands on assault weapons who
commit these crimes if you want to use
your assault weapon on a range you guess
what go to arrange and keep your gun
there and use it there I want it in my
house and why I don't understand so you
want to defend your house what you're
saying is we don't trust the population
of the country we don't think you're
autonomous we don't think you ought to
be able to make these decisions for
yourself we just don't trust you and I'm
saying why would I ever vote for someone
who wouldn't trust me to have an ar-15
at home honestly again it's like saying
we didn't trust people to drive without
seatbelts or air bags and so forth but
we instituted things that we're gonna
make people safer what we're saying is
if you don't use a car to defend
yourself and you do use a firearm to
defend yourself and why wouldn't you
know why wouldn't you trust that 330
million people in the country hundreds
of millions of them pose no conceivable
threat to anybody right so why can't we
think of a law that spares them these
regulations is anybody even trying to
think of that of course they are but
really who well but again we're taking a
step up step ask any suburban mother
that's the problem politically is that
these people that care that you lost
last time are going to be lost because
in school left is making this country
chaotic and scary and simultaneously
trying to keep me from defending myself
voters just happen not to by what you
just said care and that's why the
Democrats I don't care okay we'll see ya
Richard thank you thank you